c
maman un archi démons possède un petit
garçon de 11 ans nous avons mis lé
meilleur exorciste sur cette affaire
mais ils ont échoué
qui êtes-vous je vais aider votre fils
je ne fais pas un exorcisme
je ne me sers pas de méthode religieuse
pour soigner les gens je pénètre
l'esprit de la victime pour soigner la
maladie j'expulse les entités de
l'intérieur on est dans ta tête
réveille toi mon gars
c'est quelque chose qui va pas enrayer
[Applaudissements]
cette entité est très puissante c'est la
plus forte que j'ai jamais ressenti ce
que se passera-t-il quand elle en aura
fini avec cameron et qu'il trouverait il
mourra cameron regarde tout ça n'est
vrai tu vas brûler
oh mon dieu dione base ici
[Musique]